en el centro de nepal rescatistas buscan
entre los restos de un avión de
pasajeros la aeronave se estrelló contra
un Barranco mientras se acercaba para
aterrizar en un aeropuerto de la Ciudad
turística de pokara y se incendió
después de la colisión 72 personas
viajaban a bordo desde la capital
katmandú el Primer Ministro de nepal que
visitó la terminal aérea llamó al
personal de seguridad y al público en
general a ayudar en los esfuerzos de
rescate
el incidente fue trágico todas las
fuerzas se han desplegado para el
rescate la investigación continúa ahora
he convocado una reunión del gabinete de
emergencia y voy a estar allí
la industria aérea de nepal ha
experimentado un auge en los últimos
años pero también ha sufrido un
historial de seguridad deficiente debido
a la capacitación y a los mantenimientos
insuficientes el accidente del domingo
es el más mortífero desde 1992 en el
país cuando un airbus a 300 de Pakistán
International Airlines se estrelló cerca
de la capital dejando 167 fallecidos los
operadores de aeronaves han dicho que
nepal carece de las herramientas para
pronósticos meteorológicos precisos
especialmente en áreas remotas con
terrenos difíciles donde se han
producido múltiples accidentes mortales
en el pasado